[la musique]
Je t'ai un peu caché le motif principal
votre voyage
Je n'allume pas Berlin comme
une telle visite à la photo d'où et
sauvé par des milliers de soldats soviétiques en
monde et seulement deux personnes qui connaissent
sur ces inscriptions d'un peu plus de
autre
Voici Karen Felix la femme légendaire
La légende d'Aristov
eh bien, votre obéissant serviteur qui est sur
étudié les inscriptions pendant sept ans et mon
le rêve était de rencontrer bientôt felix
parler comme des experts
[la musique]
J'ai hâte de vous voir de la feuille
combien de kilomètres avez-vous parcouru pour cela
tous les sept ans que j'ai travaillé sur ces
les inscriptions
bien sûr je rêvais de voir en direct depuis un siècle
avec succès
Chose arabe, je ne connais que l'arabe
une phrase aéro dans le virage où es-tu
Aller
mon assistant marina ils l'ont fait à paige
et sur le site tout montrait qu'il avait vu comment on
nous nous sommes rencontrés j'étais content de voir
le bâtiment est le plus important et aujourd'hui il
juste merci ici
[la musique]
comme moi
il est ici pour la première fois
biographies de ceux-ci nom patronyme
gaiement faisons des dépôts de toutes les données
pour graphique pour 200 personnes je suis tout
le temps a dit que ces nazis sont si
mémorable pour le peuple de l'Union soviétique est
le monument que les soldats
ne sachant pas qu'ils sont très précis
nous ferons du peuple une puissance de feu
après la première reconstruction de l'extrémité de la feuille
la cinquantaine presque pas visible
les inscriptions m'ont quitté elles ont toutes été emportées
détruit
mais heureusement alors l'Allemagne était déjà apparue
cloison sèche et une partie des inscriptions laissées
sous la cloison sèche et quand a-t-il commencé
La deuxième reconstruction d'Aristov était
ces dalles furent ouvertes devant l'étonné
les yeux des bâtisseurs de l'architecte dans les ouvriers
bloqué
715 inscriptions dans leur forme originale, ces
les inscriptions
appelés autographes de victoire parce que
chacune des inscriptions est le destin de l'homme
il n'y a pas un vieil homme qui
Je suis resté là et j'ai pensé que j'étais un visage
l'armée américaine
au bar Zolotarevski
son petit-fils reconnut cette inscription tous deux arrivés
puis il l'a amené ici et il s'est avéré
c'est vraiment un très bon numéro
c'est en plus à la hauteur de nous tricotons avec vous
Je suis resté
c'est une émotion figée sur l'édition
c'est des émotions c'est des émotions c'est très
et un cabinet lui-même mundi graffiti et pose
casino
annonce fort en anglais et dans une police
ils sont fortement le siège de la direction qui se divise sur quoi
il nous vaut
Les nazis et leurs vues dans cette image
seuls beaucoup de tigres vont à l'intérieur de moi comme
au-dessus du quartier vous olya
Les Soudanais ne seraient que troisièmes en haut de la danse
mésons
nous à sasha shafik il
[ __ ] du 13 c'est mon collègue mon collègue
plus spécialiste de la récession
Oui, ce que la pierre sait, personne ne le sait
c'est comme si ça faisait des années
les appels de l'entraîneur sont un jeu d'une tête
D'accord
côté savoir bien sûr que c'est grand où
devait faire des affaires
Je pensais que je pensais que ma tâche
donc je vois
dans les unités d'artillerie, des canons étaient attachés à
le docteur et le tracteur portaient des outils lourds
il y avait des chauffeurs de tracteur actrice quelque chose comme
peu importe à quel point ils ne sont pas une profession militaire
garanin pisano dans l'enclos des russes tous
dites aux enfants ce qu'ils savent dites-leur pourquoi
ici
ce qu'ils ont vécu quand j'étais jeune
il était impossible de voir l'université
c'est pourquoi ils se sont battus avec un tel fort
mandat de raconter et de traiter mythe sens des oreilles
et français et italien et allemand
les Allemands étaient aussi contre Hitler seulement
il était impossible de montrer
ils ne se sont pas battus pour faire entrer Amerigo et
viennent nous faire le monde souvent très
jeunes pêcheurs
je sais quatorze ans quinze environ
20 c'est pire que l'ancien
cette averse gauloise au bar et un
donc il faut toujours penser
Je pense qu'ils devraient d'abord
devait finir le tien dans mon âme et
alors ils sont venus ici et ont signé pour
les murs du riz pour se débarrasser de
ce fardeau du terrible fardeau de la guerre et
commencer une nouvelle vie et ruze et je sais que
il est très important de telles situations tekke dans
autour du monde
trousses de premiers soins nouveaux national-socialistes
ces personnes et tout le monde devraient être montrés à l'extérieur
épargne pas pour
stop loss de vue et fin s'appelle
effacer
je suis en inde ukraine pour salir le mien pour un
automatique et
film eh bien c'est celui de toi waitangi
qu'en est-il de david et de l'année fiscale
sur sur sur sur sur l'union soviétique
n'arrivons pas à 16 fascisme de femme
dans le péché et appelez-le samsung dcs donc
hans termine la statue de vestig
[la musique]
ici à la fois Yegorov et Kantaria se tenaient
Que la nuit du 30 avril les voici
acheter à nouveau mimi
monté sur le toit durée de vie poussée et date
onglets relevés ok
[la musique]
expérience en direct incroyable
course naturelle ce bâtiment a l'air
très massif il en a
beauté froide
ici avec ce bâtiment quarante-cinquième année
des milliers de nos soldats ont cherché à
mettre
point gagnant dans une guerre sanglante et
trembler ainsi est la malédiction et le triomphe des guerriers
l'armée soviétique puis le riz a été pris comme ça
l'une des inscriptions les plus étonnantes
qui était écrit sur le mur de l'eristav
le sergent-chef bleu est venu à Berlin
et c'est tout
[la musique]